next on encore booknotes James Rhodes
author of Franklin the essential
founding father
the program is an hour James Rhodes
before we talk about your book Franklin
I see that you were named the author of
the best intelligence book of 2000 by
the Association of former intelligence
officers what was that about well of feo
which is the sort of holding company of
all the retired intelligence officers of
all the disciplines a defense CIA and so
on was kind enough to give me that award
and were kind enough to cooperate many
of them for the first time talking about
Allen Dulles who was something of a hero
of theirs and you jump to having a
best-selling book on John DeLorean well
yes I seem to be drawn to people who are
on the verge of narcissistic personality
was John Lurie
well John DeLorean was the General
Motors executive who founded his own car
company in the 80s and it was a very
exciting car people will remember it for
its gullwing doors and for it having
shown up in the movie Back to the Future
that series it was an ill-fated venture
and fell apart in Northern Ireland and
Arthur Andersen was the accounting firm
for it and many of the same accusations
that are being leveled today were
levelled then and now to Franklin
meaning Benjamin Franklin and you say
he's the essential founding father
what's that mean well just that I will
hyperbole aside I believe having
finished come out the end of the
research that without Franklin we would
not have had the American Revolution we
did why he was the catalyst he was that
one ingredient that took all the other
contributions of all the other founding
fathers and mothers and really created
something that was going to succeed
without Franklin I don't know that we
would be a sovereign nation
and I can argue that we probably would
still be a very small country clinging
to the Atlantic coast
I thought from reading a David macaws
book on John Adams he was that he was
the man well we all fall into that trap
of trying to make your man the essential
man but I think my case for Franklin is
stronger than his case for Adams when
did he live he lived a long time which
is part of the reason he played such a
big role he lived from 1706 to 1790 was
84 when he died which was a ripe old age
one of six to sign both the Constitution
and the Declaration of Independence one
of three to sign the Constitution the
Declaration of Independence and the
Treaty of Paris who were the other two
on the Treaty of Paris John Jay and John
Adams now how did he have himself in a
position to do all three of those well
he was of course the leading American
representative in London for nearly 20
years before that fighting in essence to
stop the revolution to get the British
government to rollback much of its
punitive taxation and and impositions
when he arrived home in defeat in 1775
he became the sort of focal point of
people who were coalescing around this
very frightening idea of breaking with
anyone England after all was how they
identified themselves
he took a role in the Declaration he
helped Jefferson write it and Jefferson
freely acknowledged that help and then
because of his international prominence
as a scientist and as a politician he
was sent back to France to try to win
French support for what was going to be
a very long and bloody war and he did
that and it was that support the guns
the tents the clothing the Gunpowder
which we could not make and the money
that won the war I say Washington won
the battles Franklin won the war he say
at the other end of the spectrum
invented these things right here
bifocals yes indeed how'd that come oh
well he was a very utilitarian man his
interests were all over the map
in fact some Harvard medical people have
suggested he may have had attention
deficit disorder but he was basically a
utilitarian he invented bifocals because
they got tired of taking one set of
glasses off and putting another set of
glasses on he invented a fireplace
because it got tired of having cold
rooms that were full of smoke he got
into electricity because lightning
burned down a lot of houses and killed a
lot of people so he was a very
utilitarian person and that infected
affected his politics did he invent
electricity not invented he made the
connection between lightning and static
electricity the kind you get when you
shuffle your foot on the rug and then
touch a doorknob and get that jolt he
discovered and proved that's the
important point he proved to others that
they were both the same thing that they
were the cause of the cause was an
imbalance in charges and he showed other
people all around the world how to prove
that to themselves so even before he
flew his kite the Franklin experiments
were being tried successfully in France
and England and Russia even and that's
where his fame came from not just the
discovery but because he shared it and
shared it with a very clear writing
style that was accessible to everybody
if he was more than 1706 at what point
in his life would he have invented
things like or you know brought
electricity to use well yeah it's a good
question because people didn't live that
long he retired he sold his prosperous
printing business sold his newspaper and
retired in his mid late 40s because he
said I don't have an awful lot of time
left a man really didn't live past 50
so is this period between 1747 1754
where he really got into a frenzy of
invention rocking chairs step ladders
for libraries he experimented with ants
and how ants communicate his interests
were extraordinary and his experiments
with electricity which first began to be
publicly known in 1751 it just rolled on
through the 1750s how did you get
interested in him in the first place
I've always been interested in Franklin
because I I'm from Pennsylvania and he
was part of my childhood history but I
was scouting around for another book
idea and I decided I didn't want to
spend a couple years of my life with
Abraham Lincoln and I started reading
more about Franklin and most of the
historians previous historians of
Franklin's life confess of frustration
and coming to grips with who was
Benjamin Franklin and the more I read
the more because of Delory and because
of allan dulles I began to say to myself
I think I know this guy this is a guy
who's really hyper charged and hyper
energetic and very cold minded very
tough and not the fat jolly fellow we
think of this is a tough customer and I
said I think I can get this guy now
there's some eclectic connections in all
this first your book is published by
Regnery yes well-known conservative book
company yes did they buy this from you
because you're conservative no not at
all to the contrary
didn't matter no and nor did they buy
the dullest book I mean Regnery has a
number of divisions they have a health
division they have their political
division which as you noticed very
conservative and very controversial and
now very best-selling but they also have
a biographical division of George
Washington and and everybody all the way
through Calvin Coolidge it was that
division that did both the Dulles and
this book and as you see they've done a
splendid job but it was endorsed by
three people on the back
I'll hunt who is not a conservative not
at all Susan Eisenhower the daughter of
John Isner and Roger Kennedy yes did you
have anything to do with getting those
endorsements oh yeah
of course what's your connection to
those three well Roger Kennedy was very
kind
Roger Kennedy for your listeners is a
former head of the American History
Museum at the Smithsonian former head of
the National Park Service a historian of
the first water in his own right
biographer of Thomas Jefferson and Aaron
Burr and Alexander Hamilton and was very
kind to me about the Dulles book so he's
become a friend and mentor Susan
Eisenhower as a friend and I admire her
and her work at the Eisenhower Institute
and al hunt and I go away way back
he's a device Oh to the Treasury press
room when I was at UPI and he was with
the Wall Street Journal how long were
you with UPI two years and something
when did you start in the business 1958
Jame Ford I was a student journalist
covering the freedom bus rides went to
work for the Tampa Times worked on
through the south as a reporter and
ended up at the Atlanta Journal and
wrote stuff for Newsweek and then came
to Washington how long I mean what were
the years that you were with GPI 67
through 72
Businessweek Bureau here Forbes magazine
here went to work with a my own little
news service and that was with papers
like the London Telegraph our Eastern
Economic Review doing mainly finance and
economic things that lasted 26 years so
you know when do you write your first
book of the delorean book in the early
80s and it was actually a part of a
series of articles about John DeLorean
because that was such a big story in
Britain because the factory was in
Northern Ireland and it was really part
of first the Callahan and in the
Thatcher government's effort to bring
industrial development to Northern
Ireland and it was such a disaster and
what book is this then for you
six we've what were the other three that
we haven't mentioned there did the same
co-author and I the same finance editor
of The Sunday Telegraph and I did a book
on the takeover characters and then
worked on a biography with him of James
Goldsmith the financier and then I do
they biography sort of potted character
sketches of the 14 presidential
candidates in the 96 election and the
names Rhodes what kind of a name is it
it's a Pittsburgh name what country
originally would ever come Strasburg by
our family legend and we were among the
indentured servants who came to
Pennsylvania the first we have record of
1800 so obviously we came before that
you write about the Benjamin Franklin's
connection to the pens and also the
William Pitt
I assume that's Pennsylvania and
Pittsburgh oh yes looms very large start
with the Pens who were they well William
Penn was the son of a famous Admiral who
was owed a great deal of money by King
Charles for having won a famous naval
victory over the Dutch he died and young
William who had become a Quaker which
was very controversial couldn't get the
money out of the king but the king gave
him a large grant of land in the back of
beyond which he named after his father
most people think
Pennsylvania's named after William Penn
is named after Admiral Penn and also
included Delaware and parts of New
Jersey it was huge it was an enormous
piece of land and he set it up as a
Quaker settlement and was very kind to
the Indians and unfortunately his heirs
turned out to be greedy grasping and
duplicitous
and the worst of them was a man named
Thomas Penn who came out in the 1740s to
get as much money as he could out of the
Indians and tricked them and duped them
and bribed them and fed them rum and
generally cheated them out of even more
land
and became an enemy of Benjamin Franklin
because Franklin began to write against
him and this was at a time when the
press was a new thing the power of the
press
to make fun of people was particularly
poisonous I mean and you could go to
jail
you could be exiled you could have your
presses destroyed by the government for
writing against the government you
couldn't even report debates in the
Parliament or the colonial legislatures
so Franklin took a lot of risk and he
made a lifelong enemy Penn's life tomas
penz life a lifelong enemy out of Penn
and Penn took it out on Pennsylvania
what about Pitts Pitts was of course one
of those meteors that cross the English
sky I mean he was a complex character he
was from the very start a an advocate
for the rights of the people even though
he didn't really liked the people to be
around him he was very much an
aristocrat but he was honest which was
unusual he was skillful which was even
more unusual he ran the French and
Indian War with enormous success far
more success than they deserved and he
was a friend of America and he was a
friend of Franklin's and we would have
been a lot better off if Pitt had lived
long enough but he didn't Benjamin
Franklin was born where to what parents
born 1706 to a boston candle and soap
maker named Josiah Franklin and his
second wife Abiah Josiah Franklin had 17
children by his two wives extraordinary
crowded family the 13 of them were
around at any one time by Franklin's
reminiscence
they weren't poor but they were
scrapping and Josiah was a
Congregationalist which meant that he
was constantly reexamining his
conscience
trying to perfect himself and while
Benjamin left that church almost as soon
as he could that's stuck within this
constant perfection inward-looking
effort to improve oneself to find virtue
which wasn't a single quality it was a
multiple of qualities that you sought
stuck with him all of his life he was
apprenticed to a half-brother as a
printer apprentice ran away when he was
seventeen didn't have much formal
schooling only had three years in a
school but became an omnivorous reader
and turned to writing very skillful
parodies which he had published
anonymously without his brothers knowing
in his brothers newspaper ran away when
he was seventeen got to Philadelphia
managed to get the London which was the
center of printing skills where he
perfected his techniques but this time
he was a really strong guy people think
of Franklin as being as I said fat and
sedentary this was a real horse of a guy
tall was five-nine five-ten but to be a
printer in those days you had to be
extraordinarily robust and I have a
great upper body strength he was also a
quite well-known swimmer and at one
point considered taking up the trade of
professional swimming instructor and
Aquatic star but he stayed with printing
came back to Philadelphia bought a
newspaper by the time he was 27 he was
running the most popular widely read
newspaper in the colonies it was the
story of where he became a vegetarian in
order to save money so they could buy
more books he was this little while he
was apprenticed to his brother and he
and his Franklin's don't get along with
each other they scrap and they quarrel
and it was like a little bear garden and
his brother and all the other
apprentices boarded at a boarding house
and partly to annoy his brother but also
to save money
he said well look if you'll just give me
the money that you paid to have me fed
I'll feed myself and
adopted a vegetarian regime and was able
to save half the money which he spent on
books he drove on vegetarianism up to
the point when he got tired of it and
then he quit did he write a lot of books
in his life not books pamphlets he was
an exhausting pamphlet here pamphlets
were an extraordinary political device
if he wrote his first one while he was
still a printer in London dissertation
on morals which was terribly
embarrassing because he was very
superficial and young but he became
probably the best pamphleteer of the age
he published them anonymously published
him under other people's names he
published them under his own name and
kept up a drum fire of agitation for
American rights that drove the British
government mad what year did he write
his own autobiography he wrote it in two
installments he wrote it in the early
seventh one installment which was really
in the form of a letter to his son
William who by that point was about to
be a royal governor named a royal
governor of New Jersey and it was more
of a letter like Lord Chesterfield to
his son than pointing out how you
overcome personal vice and how you
become more virtuous and then he wrote a
second installment later many years
later he never wrote a complete
autobiography but he wrote really about
the most interesting and and least
public of his years is growing up his
family background and his own struggles
with immorality and licentiousness you
can find that autobiography almost
everywhere oh yes it's in paperback
knowledge and you know any no do you
know of any the number of it still still
sells oh and it still sells in the
hundreds every year I mean or maybe even
the thousands there are several editions
of it there's a very good one in
paperback edited by the distinguished
Franklin scholarly olam a how important
was it to you to read that to get ready
for this
Kiros oh it's very important because it
confirmed in my mind that you oughta
read people's autobiographies but you
ought to read it with a very large
spoonful of salt I mean it was this was
a letter the first part was a letter to
his son saying look at the mistakes I've
made and here's how you ought to improve
yourself you know you're a lot like me
you tend to be a bit of a jerk about
women you tend to spend too much money
you like these easy life now take it
from me try to be a better guy and then
the second part which he wrote at a
friend's home in France was really more
of a justification of his political
career up to the revolution his son you
say was illegitimate yes how well-known
was that back then and who was the woman
that had his illegitimate son it was
known instantly it was publicly known it
was written about at the time he was his
enemies used it as a stick to beat him
the woman is not known although there
been two books each nominating a
different character it is probably true
that she was a woman a prostitute or at
least someone that he had no intention
of marrying and hit the woman he did
marry Deborah Reed took William in as a
infant and raised him as as what he was
Franklin's first son they had two more
children of their own their marriage by
the way it was a common-law marriage
because she'd married before and that
husband had run away and she couldn't
prove that he was dead what was your
relationship between Benjamin Franklin
and his son William my take is that
Franklin wasn't really a great parent he
he spoiled his children his daughter and
another son who died fairly young but he
spoiled William but he held back that
sort of unconditional love that parents
have
and so if he wanted to be daddy's son
you'd had to do what daddy said so
William lived for quite a while in
Franklin shadow then he became a royal
governor in his own right
actually higher than his father
appointed by the king appointed by the
king married a wealthy planters daughter
from Barbados and it was actually living
at a higher station and his father when
the war broke out
Williams stayed loyal to the king was
arrested and finally shipped off to
England where he became the leading
advocate for reparations for the
loyalists after the war and he died over
there
Franklin cut him off just as if he never
existed indeed took William Franklin's
son William temple Franklin away from
him and made him Benjamin Franklin's
private secretary and took temple to
Paris you say that William Franklin at
the very end came to his father for
money yes he was broke why would he be
broke after the king and made him a
royal governor and well but he was no
longer a royal governor you've got your
money from the taxes you're the share of
taxes you raked off for the king that
ended in 1776 Oh by-the-by 1783 William
was him hard hard straits and also wrote
I think too you know reconcile himself
with his father Franklin wasn't having
any of it
just rebuked him you say he crossed the
Atlantic eight times yes
and it's an astonishing thing and that
he spent 26 years of his life outside
the United States in France and in
England Ireland Germany this was a man
for whom travel was like vitamins I mean
he said often if I know travel I don't
feel well and we think of George
Washington as being this rugged
outdoorsman on horseback riding through
the Alleghenies Benjamin Franklin went
from Williamsburg Virginia to Maine back
and forth routinely for months on end as
Postmaster General planning routes
fighting bridges finding mail drops
finding riders to ride the post he would
be gone for months on in and when he got
the London he was all over the British
Isles went to Ireland went to Scotland
and a number of times at a time when
there really weren't any roads he just
traveled travel travel hop and go back
over those trips were there for trips in
total for yes and those four trips were
how long did he live in these in the
countries over there at a time and where
were they in his life well he first went
to London as a very young man to work
for close to two years as a young
printer then he came home so let's say
that's two trip that's one trip one more
round trip then he went back in 1757 and
he was there until 1762 as the colonial
agent the lobbyist if you will for
Pennsylvania Georgia New Jersey and late
lastly Massachusetts this is right up
against the cusp paid individually by
those colonies paid by the General
Assemblies to look to their interests
and he'd been close to 50 then oh yeah
yeah well he was 51 when he first went
so he was getting on there then he came
home my way is his wife ever go with him
and he's never stripped never went never
so for 26 years she was never with him
overseas in so far as I can tell she
never got any further than her son's
home in New Jersey
so the third trip on the netted the
third trip he came home in 1762 in kind
of disgrace because he'd tried to get
the King to take the Royal Charter for
Pennsylvania away from the Pens and it
was a no-hoper
a the King didn't have the money and B
he didn't have any more desire to run
Pennsylvania than the Pens did there was
a huge political upheaval Franklin found
himself although all during this time
he'd been a member of the Pennsylvania
General Assembly find himself voted out
of office one month and a couple of
months later he found himself being
unanimously chosen
go back to London so he went back in
1764 and he was there till 1775 he
sailed back in 1775 what'd he do then
over while while he was there he was
again trying to get some sort of reforms
because the whole nature of colonies was
the American colonies was changing and
the Americans knew it and the British
refused to acknowledge it colonies were
supposed to feed the mother country no
decent Englishmen went out to a colony
and planned to stay the only people
would plan to stay in colonies were
people who were on the run religious
dissenters and people of the second
class King George the third took over
when in 1762 he was very young man he
six was he succeeded his grandfather who
george ii ii and was very popular at the
beginning because he was supposed to
have been raised in a reformist
household and so Franklin thought well
not here's like here's our chance to get
a benevolent king who will take over and
save the colonies and it turned out that
George the third wanted none of them no
reform no innovation is nothing 1962 how
old was George the third oh he was just
in his early 20s he was a very young man
and very much under the influence of his
tutors and advisors which one of these
Kings came from Germany well George the
first was German and spoke only German
George the second was born in Germany
but lived most of his life as an adult
in England and spoke bad English George
the third was the only one born in
England raised in England who spoke good
English and bad German did I remember
you say that he came back to the United
States and only strips in about 75
Benjamin Franklin 1875 uh yes that's
right because we're getting near the
Declaration of Independence well while
he while he was all
while he was coming back on this third
trip Lexington and Concord occurred and
the war was on so the question is do we
go ahead with the war do we declare
independence and this is this debate
lasted all the way through 1775 and 1776
and was really an open question until
that convention in the summer of 76 and
there were numbers of people George
Washington Thomas Jefferson Samuel Adams
who said oh no we've got to we've got to
get some last-minute deal and there was
a petition in the summer of 75 which
Franklin drafted a last petition to the
king saying look you've got to stop this
and George the third refused to even
look at it and indeed turn the screws
sent more troops and Franklin undertook
this extraordinary journey now this is
1775 so he's looking on 260 goes by sled
hauls M&T yeah I'm sorry you're right
who goes all the way all the way to
Canada to try to talk the Canadians into
joining in and they won't have any of it
so he has to come all the way back
nearly dies gets back on his feet is
there for the Declaration of
Independence by the way all through this
he's got a lot of sickness gout which
was awful if you've ever had gout what
way is it well it's a it's a it's a
failure of your kidneys to process uric
acid and it the surplus your uric acid
calexis crystals in your joints and it's
like having grains of sand in those
joints and it affects your feet it
affects your hands and your elbows your
knees and it's just excruciating and
then you have urinary tract stones that
affect our just you might as well dawn
when did he have the pleurisy attack oh
that he had his first pleurisy attack
when he was quite young when he first
came back from London on this printing
tor and again I mean these the health
risks of the this age are extraordinary
I mean men were lucky to live 250 women
were lucky to live to 40 and and the
smoky fireplaces we talk about air
pollution now the air pollution of major
cities was an extraordinary health
hazard and tuberculosis and all the
other things that pleurisy which is an
infection of the outer layers of your
lungs nearly killed him and he was
susceptible to it all of his life
when did he live in France throughout
all these trips well he visited France
during his second tour in London where
he was celebrated and honored as the
electrician and the the new Newton he
met Louis the 15th was celebrated and
honored and made a fellow of royal
academies in Germany and and Brussels
and and in Russia and so on and so he
traveled widely in Europe that was his
first contact with the French
intelligentsia and it was where I was
able to find and demonstrate that he
made the first context with the French
merchants who were rounding up supplies
and shipping things in speculation that
we were going to go to war with Britain
what was the relationship between France
and Britain in those years Oh an
antipathy that transcended anything
we've ever known in the cold war was
like a minuet compared to how the French
and English hated each other why well
there had been nearly a hundred and
fifty unbroken years of warfare between
them they had nearly destroyed each
other and they were an intense
competition for these worldwide colonies
which were subsidizing the life of the
nations at home you couldn't have these
kings in these courts if you didn't have
people laboring in the rice paddies in
the cane fields of places millions of
miles away do I remember that he lived
in France for nine years at one point
yes and when was John Adams there with
him and John Jay well
right after the Declaration of
Independence
just as the British troops are coming in
earnest to land on Long Island the ha
brothers William and Richard to confront
Washington the French sent secret
emissaries to say look if you're really
serious about this war we'll help you we
don't want to get into war with the
British but you know there are these
islands down in the Caribbean where
we'll ship stuff under our own flag and
then if your people can get them into
these hundreds of little waterways that
dot your atlantic coast
well we'll sell you stuff lend you stuff
we'll take tobacco and Anjou and things
in trade what do you say so they the
Continental Congress sent a number of
people to France but most importantly
they sent Franklin as the person to get
a formal declaration of recognition of
the United States and a trade treaty
that was really important and they sent
a number of other they empowered another
two other people who turned out to be
just awful and enemies of Franklin to
help him and to see similar treaties
from Spain and Holland and the other
courts of Europe which Franklin
disapproved of he said you know come on
these monarchies aren't gonna help us
the only reason the French King is
interested in helping us is not out of
any love of Liberty it's to get back at
Britain which came wasn't this by this
point was louis xvi and who was Benjamin
Franklin not getting along with from the
United States or from the time.they
colonies well the Lee family of Virginia
and the Adams family of Massachusetts
Samuel and John particularly John we're
suspicious of anybody from the so called
middle colonies both Virginians and
people from New England thought of
themselves as the natural aristocrats of
the colonies and these tradesmen were
just not
the kind of person you wanted
representing you abroad so the first
people to come to Franklin's aid were
William and Arthur Lee who were living
in London whooping it up having a
general good time and being very
ambitious and they came to Paris
ostensibly to help but all they really
did was write complaining letters back
to Philadelphia saying how Franklin was
balling up the accounts and not getting
the thing done with the French I
populations you say the Great Britain
back then was about 8 million people yes
this country 1.6 million 55 I think well
no bye-bye
17 yeah by 1750 there was 1.7 million by
1770 there were 2 point 1 million
biggest city in the United States
Philadelphia how big was it there it's
about 30,000 people it was the biggest
city in the British Empire next to
London it was bigger than Liverpool
bigger than Manchester bigger than
Sheffield it had had a commercial
explosion it's an interesting factoid
that between 1770 and 1780 even with the
loyalists fleeing hundreds of thousands
of loyalist families population of the
thirteen colonies 13 states grew by half
a million people and Franklin kept
warning people about this he kept saying
look people are coming here we're having
children at a young age we're
reproducing ourselves at a fantastic
rate we're going to be larger than you
we're an enormous market for your goods
we're loyalty try to treat us better
than English weren't having any you used
a word earlier licentiousness when it
came to Ben Franklin how many that were
quick a quick thing
Deborah his wife died in what year she
died in December 1774 how long had they
been married
since 1730's 49 years and 26 of those
years or he's gone he's gone and even I
mean even during the years he was in
America he was gone and she had he how
many of his children she had to a son
died of smallpox and but a daughter
lived on and had multitudes of
grandchildren
Sally Sally the licentiousness of Lynn
Franklin gave a lot of mistresses you
name a bunch in here well by the time he
took the French mistresses he was a
widow
he but you know this is you've stuck a
needle in me because I'm I'm a little
sensitive to this popular attack on
historical figures trying to tar them
with the same brush of many of our
contemporary political figures Franklin
in the autobiography says that one of
the reasons they got married was he was
he didn't like consorting with
prostitutes it was expensive it was more
trouble than it was worth and there was
this terrible risk of disease but he
consorted with them then he got married
he had numerous flirtatious friendships
with many of the wealthy young women of
the colonies and his enemies picked up
on that and Williams illegitimate birth
my take on it is women in the 18th
century of property were property and no
family it was gonna risk their
daughter's reputation at the hands of a
man like Franklin and nor were the nor
were the women
Franklin it's too much I think to call
him if an early feminist but Franklin
saw in young women who were trying to
educate themselves and try to raise
themselves a kind of fellow sympathy
he helped women all of his life he help
women become printer
I known their own printing businesses he
appointed the first woman postmaster and
his friendships in England were the same
kind of avuncular nature now when i got
to paris he did have two very
significant love affairs both with
titled ladies one was married one was a
widow and the only one he proposed to
was the widow is that which one is
Madame Brianna Brianna was the married
woman who was a bit of a neurotic but
very talented and say deeply loved
Benjamin Franklin they both did both
both of these fake blood and yes look
Lopez Lopez yes it was a distinguished
Yale historian who has written several
books about Franklin and his women and
who shares my view that people were a
little more robust in their affections
in those days people were a little more
frank
he flattered them he professed affection
he wrote poems and they in turn returned
the affection who was Catherine raygreen
Catherine raygreen was another one of
these young American women that Franklin
took an enormous liking to she ended up
the wife of the governor of Rhode Island
and maintained a very vocal affection
for Franklin that lasted all of her life
largely because what he had talked to
her about and told her about and
encouraged her to read and so on who was
that Polly Stevenson Hewson Polly
Stevenson was the daughter of his
longtime landlady in London she was a
bit of a prim and proper lass but he she
became a protege for him as well and she
married one of Britain's great surgeons
and in fact came to Philadelphia when
she was a widow brought her sons with
her and those sons became among
America's first great surgeons as well
and she was at his bedside when he died
he was aunt Catherine
and Catherine last name is it's like
Helvetia sir oh well that was the the
one he proposed to Madame Helvetia al
Vicious was a famous French philosopher
and Mason and her estate adjoined the
estate where he Franklin lived outside
of Paris she was kind of a bohemian
woman offended Abigail Adams mightily
for not being for being a little loose
and rowdy
she was always kissing Franklin on the
cheeks and the mussing his hair and
sitting in his lap and that offended
Abigail mightily and he proposed to her
and it she had to think about it she to
give up everything and come to the wilds
of America was just too much for her
though go back to these trips back and
forth how long did it take for him to
get from say London or you know
Southampton to where we left to come to
the United States on a ship well it took
generally a month to get from west to
east and it could take two months to go
from east to west because of the
prevailing winds
well there's one example you you use in
1757 where he ended up having to sit in
the harbor here in the United States for
how long before he could take off to go
to three months just literally off the
coast you say hey total June couldn't
leave the ship didn't dare leave the
ship because at any minute the governor
of New York military commander of New
York could say file his last dispatch
and say all right let the ship go but
because he kept writing dispatches the
ship's stay ships in those days went in
convoy because Britain was always at war
and so you you didn't sail until the
rest of the ship sailed let me go to the
religious thing because you talk about
the Quakers well but you say he was he
was not a quick here no no I want to
read what you did write about him you
see Franklin steadfastly refused to
accept most of the doctrinal mysteries
of established Christianity including
the divinity of Jesus along with Buddha
Muhammad and other religious figure
heads
Jesus was relegated to being an
admirable exemplar and teacher and an
intercessor with divine providence but
no more how did he fit in than with the
rest of the founding fathers back then
was he a deist he was his own Chi
invented his own form of deism Thomas
Jefferson was a deist although I think
Jefferson put Jesus a little higher in
the category of ancillary divine beings
Jefferson of course as you know cut up a
Bible took the four Gospels of Matthew
Mark Luke and John and cut out all the
extraneous matter and left only Jesus's
statements and that book that book is
still available it's called the
Jefferson Bible oh there were a lot of
dias this was part of the Enlightenment
as I said in the book once you cut off a
king's head once you cut off God's
anointed monarch then you can ask any
question you want you can talk to God
directly and if you don't get the
answers you want from God you can invent
your own answers Franklin got tired of
churchmen for the same reason he didn't
like lawyers he didn't like be pleased
the ass tickles he felt that too many of
the clergies
interests were in making docile parishes
and not enough in really working toward
virtue and getting to God so his God
whom he called God but most of the time
called Providence was way out there he
was beyond our mortal reach but you
could reach God through Buddha through
Allah through Moses or any of the
Talmudic intercessors but the best thing
you could do to reach God and to please
God and to ensure your own salvation was
to help other men and he believed that
in too great sincerity you mentioned
virtues and you say in the book that
there 13 virtues well he
30 May that went at what point in his
life did he do this well very young he
started on this on the trip back from
London as a young printer and he worked
at it systematically for the next 25
years at least he drew up a list of 13
virtues I've got him here in case you
want him go ahead he started I think
with the ones that he could control most
easily temperance I can't see put on
camera oh okay we got temperance and
silence and order and I think redemption
and frugal frugality I'm gonna drop this
sewing read him I think I'm most at no
resolution not the redemption industry
sincerity justice moderation cleanliness
tranquility chastity and humility how do
you do on chastity well you notice the
chastity is that near the enter the end
yes he's he wanted to give up these
rowdy youth he wanted to get away from
the punch bowl it made him silly it made
him a joker and a punster and he wanted
to be taken seriously he wanted to be
industrious and he worked his way down
this list adopting a virtue every week
and really concentrating it day by day
and then at the end of the week you'd
say well was I temperate this week and
if he'd got good marks he'd move on to
the next one so that by doing all 13 in
sequence he would revisit these virtues
four times every year four times
thirteen and he got to chastity chastity
was originally the last of his concerns
which tells me that he had gotten up
pretty well under control and he showed
this list to a Quaker elder he respected
and the Quaker said you know you might
be a little more humble about
his Franklin was saying look how
virtuous I am I follow this list and so
he added the 13th other things on the
list you you say that did I think you
said he he started the University of
Pennsylvania yes well it was an Academy
the Academy was the foundation of what
is now the University of Pennsylvania
fundraising for free hospital yep
what did that mean he raised the money
he was he was the first one to propose
matching grants he went to the General
Assembly and said look we need a
hospital free hospital here in
Philadelphia smallpox would come racing
through the town and kill hundreds I
think assembly said now we can't afford
it and Franklin said if I can raise half
the money privately will you come up
with the rest and they fell for it and
that's how the Philadelphia hospital is
is still in existence the first fire
insurance yes
nationwide first time ever ever ever he
invented the fire companies first the
idea that you would subscribe to a fire
company that you would put a plaque on
your door and when your house caught
fire your chimney caught fire that
company would come and put out the fire
of course if they were busy elsewhere
you were you were done for so he said
you know we can we pull all the
companies and we can insure against fire
damage through these resources and yes
the first fire insurance what about the
first modern postal delivery system when
Franklin took over the post office
you're a letter to me would be dumped on
a tavern table and anybody could come by
and say oh here Brian lambs written to
Jim's Road I wonder what he's saying and
I open it up or letters disappeared or
the government spied on you routinely
Franklin not only ended that gave secure
mail service but he have the time
between the time of letter could be
posted in Philadelphia and
come back from Boston which was some do
it I'm not sure this is way pronounce it
but gent oh that's what it was the whole
yeah in just a in what was that in his
life this was his first real effort at
self-improvement he got twelve
like-minded men and it always stayed at
twelve although the membership changed
dramatically over the years and these
twelve met on Friday night over a
Punchbowl and they would systematically
again Franklin and the lists they would
go down a list of of topics
self-improving topics what new business
have you heard of what new who's gotten
sick who's in trouble is there anybody
we can help it's your turn to tell an
essay give us an essay give us a poem
and they stuck together and they
improved each other's minds and they
lent each other's books which is how the
library the first lending library came
anyway we know in the group no not as
such I mean they many of them went on to
enormous prominence and wealth but
nobody by name what about Poor Richard's
Almanack what's that
well almanacs were a profitable line
that most printers produced and they
were ostensibly to tell the farmer when
to plant and when the moon would be full
and other useful items Franklin took the
basic Almanac format and added humor and
satire and a little political insight a
little political editorial ization and
he created this fictional character
Richard Saunders poor Richard Saunders
who was an astrologer and was down at
the heels and his Saunders wife was
always nagging at him and he created
really the first great literary
character in America everybody had a
wife or knew somebody whose wife was as
naggy as with Richard Saunders wife and
there were pranks that he played but and
basically the crop information and the
the phases of the Moon were accurate
enough but because Franklin was also the
postman
to general and because so many of his
relatives had printing shops and were
postmasters under his patronage Poor
Richard's Almanack became the most
popular almanac in America it sold
10,000 copies a year which would be 2
million copies today at 10 pence which
would be you know like 40 or $50 today
it was an enormous source of profit but
it was also an enormous source of
influence you say that he owned slaves
but yet was the first spokesman for the
abolition movement he was the primary
spokesman there are others who had come
against that the Quakers had always been
against slavery although william pan had
own slaves he probably bought his first
slave in the 1740s when he was in his
30s yeah and his progression I mean his
father had allowed slaves to be sold in
front of his candle factory in Boston in
the 1720s and 30s I mean Boston was a
major slave port New York was a major
slave port many of the great families of
Massachusetts built part of their
fortunes on that triangular trade that
include bringing slaves to so young Ben
Franklin saw slaves being auctioned
under his father's shop son by the time
he hit his 40s he began to make and
write an economic criticism of slavery
that slavery really didn't pay the owner
that it was a poor way to use manpower
by the time he got to England of course
England was already beginning an
anti-slavery groundswell of opinion and
he met many of the leading abolitionists
and became the president of an effort to
build schools in America for young
blacks we're running out of time and you
say that he knew David Hume who was a
member was that the bridge it was in
favor of checks and balances
but when he was involved in the writing
of the Constitution a member of the
Constitution convention but almost
nothing that he supported I was
successful in the Constitution Franklin
was far more radical and suspicious of
power than Hume Hume believed you could
set up checks and balances Franklin
believed that the only way you could
check unlicensed power was to limit he
believed in one-year terms in office he
believed in a plural executive in other
words when he was governor of
Pennsylvania during the time between his
return at the end of the war and the
Constitution he shared that office with
two other men he believed that the
presidency should be through a three-man
job and one only in one unicameral one
house one house popularly elected but
then when that stalled would not became
impossible he came up with the Senate
compromise how long did it take you to
write this book better part of two years
what is different about your book than
all the others you read I tried to deal
with Franklin's character which
mystified many of his biographers and I
did a lot of research in London in Paris
which a lot of other people haven't done
what's your next move
I'm not telling when do you expect to
have it done I'm gonna take a while I'm
gonna take probably five years in there
why do you not tell because other people
write books as quickly as I do here is
the cover of the book our guest has been
James Rhodes and the name of this book
is Franklin the essential founding
father Benjamin Franklin who died after
84 years on this earth thank you very
much for joining thank you Brian
Franklin Neah central founding father is
published by Regnery on the web at
Regnery dot-com next week on encore
booknotes of Paradise and power
Robert Kagan's comparative look at
America and Europe